alors bernard tapie comme vous êtes le
roi de la tchatche vous allez finir mes
phrases et je vous donne mes débuts
comme donner enfin en ce moment je sais
pas ce que j'aimais ça se présente pas
mal c'est bien un truc que je sais pas
faire c'est faire semblant
la seule différence entre le théâtre et
la politique c'est quand on tue au
théâtre c'est pour faire rire ce qui
manque à chirac par rapport à mitterrand
c'est jacques séguéla le seul truc que
j'ai jamais pu m'offrir avec l'argent
c'est le crédit lyonnais
je me serai remboursé plus tôt
pas pourquoi mais en général je plie aux
femmes qui ont conlu goût du risque
c'est vrai au moins franchement
maintenant je peux te dire l'émission
que je faisais sur tf1 je regrette de
l'avoir arrêté
allez allez
comme tu as une bonne tête mais montre
en or je tirais l'âge pour pour
t'apprendre que tu fais pas la
différence entre l'acier laurent david
est prêté des barreaux en quoi on a
chanté
non mais il a été sympa avec moi parce
qu'un jour j'ai gardé ça et je vais
garder un on est on faisait les missions
sur canal juste avant que j'y aille vie
j'ai un truc pour toi tu le regardes ça
quand tu seras partie à une tribune qu
un proche et quand je sors je regarde ce
que c'est c'était du monopoly vous êtes
libéré de prison
c'est bien
tapisser le seul ministre c'est remettre
son micro en direct à la télévision
thierry cette incroyable depuis la
dernière fois ce que tu as tu semble
plus heureux mais il n'y a même pas de
comparaison c'est le soir qui était sa
salle et gagnent tous deux sont vraiment
porte bien le deuil je sens que ça y est
quoi voilà le jour mais 60 ans je me
suis dit tout marche à et tout marche
ah ouais t'as besoin de viagra du cialis
et là dedans le bafa est franchement si
tu avais été au ballon à ma place je
suis sûr que tu en es boîte et alors ça
aurait été plus normal ça aurait fait
plus normal merde
le combat le plus dur que j'ai eu à
mener ses chansons de brassens qui dit
les gens n'aiment pas que l'on suive pas
le même chemin que ouais bah c'est un
peu ce contre cela que c'était dur et
mauvaise réputation c'est ce qu'ils
veulent pas qu'on soit différent quoi et
ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui ce qui me rend le plus fier
c'est mes enfants les quatre c'est
marrant malgré tout ce que j'ai vécu je
continue à croire que qu'il faut
toujours y croire
des fois je me dis si seulement j'avais
pas alors ça je me le dis jamais jamais
jamais pas une fois je me suis dit ah si
j'avais su mais c'est ce que j'aime dans
la vie j'ai pas de rétroviseur mais par
contre je garde c'est ce qui fait que je
garde jamais de mauvais souvenirs des
gens qui m'ont fait chier je promets à
celui qui me traitent encore dans à dix
mètres un passé sur sont des souvenirs
d'un truc chez moi j'aimerais que ce
soit j'ai fait une des écoles pour les
jeunes qui étaient sans boulot ouais et
on à la sortie près de 10000 sans rien
demander à personne et il y en a près de
10000 dans la nature
ouais que rue belle carrière rassam
parmi tous les salopards qui m'ont trahi
je n'oublierai jamais peint que mes
pattes étaient pas dans le lot et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou